vous voulez entrer un stanford
oui j'ai vu de très bons résultats à mes
évaluations donc vous n'êtes pas un
élève est ce qu'on peut écrire je
comprends pas à part étudiante élèves
comme un vrai tempérament artistique où
vous avez certaines écuries
toi tu es la plus sublime des créatures
[Musique]
ça jamais eu l'impression que monde
entier et rejette comme s'il te disais
que tu ne voulais pas vu je me demande
comment survit quand on enlève les
pousse toi de là produits veronica est
prononcé dans le seigneur des anneaux tu
voulais parler de quasimodo le bossu de
notre dame
je voulais dire par là que te regarde et
me donne envie de m'arracher les yeux
[Musique]
qui toi j'ai rencontré quelqu'un ont
fait exploser c'est très clair qu'il me
prend pour quelqu'un d'autre c'est de
l'usurpation d'identité c'est totalement
illégal
non mais je rêve veronica veronica et je
vais être en concurrence avec elle sur
les milliards des numéros qu'il ya dans
le monde il est tombé sur l'émir tu as
quand même besoin d'être réglo ces mémos
c'est à moi qu'il veut parler
mais plus qu'un beau gosse du football r
non parce que tu me trouves beau gosse
non parce que ça te dirait de sortir
avec moi je sais que tu as donné mon
numéro à des mecs au hasard ya là alors
je crois qu'on peut peut-être
s'entraider mais je te demande un petit
service
t'es sûr que ça va marcher non j'étais
sûr de rien j'ai prêté mon salut salut
c'est une bonne journée c'est bizarre le
son de ta voix est légèrement décalé on
ferait mieux de remettre ça un soir où
ça fonctionne ouais bien sûr j'y arrive
pas
tu crois que tu pourrais craqué sur moi
tu corresponds totalement tu es mon
genre
est-ce que tu as une idée de l'enfer et
fait face pour mettre de l'essence dans
la peau d'une vie aux belges
c'est ce qui est le plus dur qu'on se
sent affreusement minérale
[Musique]
je lui dois la vérité je me sens pas
prêt
je sais pas qui tu es je te reconnais
autant je crois connaître avant
vous la connaissez pas elle est super
cool comme si la terrifiante candia moi
je sais pas keshi
[Musique]